breaking news from Afghanistan a
passenger planes reportedly crashed near
the center of the deck district in the
eastern province of Ghazni all right
let's go live to the Afghan capital
Kabul speak to our correspondent Zayn
burs Ravi what more do we know Zayn well
Martine since we last spoke there have
been some serious developments in this
case it turns out that the spokesman for
the governor of Ghazni province our if
Nuri the spokesman has been speaking
from that province and has said that
according to his people on the ground
this is not an Afghan aircraft so that
would suggest that it is not an Ariana
Airlines aircraft as previously was
suspected by many people now we were
hearing that the government was
deploying troops to the area and we know
that Afghan security forces are at the
scene and reports were hearing from
those eyewitnesses is that all
passengers on board are deceased there
are no survivors and only the pilots
bodies are recognizable at this stage
and those Afghan soldiers are saying
that as far as they're concerned from
the wreckage and from from the bodies of
those pilots that they do not appear to
be Afghan and this does not appear to be
an Afghan aircraft and now in coming
hours it does beg the question of what
aircraft was this who did it belong to
and what was it doing flying over that
area all questions that we're still
waiting for answers to Zane thank you